Peggy 18 the augmented era began with
such promise until the incidents turn
the world upside down
50 million dead hundreds of thousands
more maimed and injured all because a
few rich opportunists plotted in secret
to control us today hatred amongst has
morphed into a full-blown mechanical
apartheid with violent clashes fueling
unrest the Augmented are suffering the
genocide it begins with taking away our
rights treating us as less than human
and then exterminating us something big
is brewing and I need to cut it off at
the source how can these people always
be one step ahead
we've got unlimited power and money and
absolutely no conscience at all
they manipulated the dawn of human 2.0
made it dangerous made me a boy use
every advantage I have to stop them
my advanced capabilities convinced
Interpol to recruit mater to
counterterrorism task force despite
objections within the team I'm willing
to ensure their prejudice so long as it
furthers my hunt for the truth threat
not gonna go all wonky on us now answer
oh yeah if I do McCready guarantee
you'll never see it coming
turns out my military-grade enhancements
we're hiding a full set of cutting-edge
experimental logs you're telling me I
got more implants than I thought I did
more than your body can handle meaning
my ability to infiltrate
fights and circumstance has now grown
exponentially
right along with the increasing threat
level
being stationed in Prague places me at
the epicenter of terrorist activity and
with blame for the latest atrocity being
leveled at an Augmented group there the
only certainty is that the body count
will keep rising our territory is
fiercely defended no one said supported
the task force wants me to bring works
leader to justice dealing with his
augmented army as I see fit
starting my investigation by
interrogating Talos Rucker upon the
realities of his non-violence approach
could prove beneficial every floor of
their towering complex is packed with
armed militia and filled with high-end
security but it's makeshift construction
provides me with plenty of options going
in full force and guns blazing may
result in casualties but if I want too
strong on Rooker just rendering it makes
sense to use force engaging them with
modified firearms explosive nano blades
and using my Titan shield to negate
their counter fire as I roll through
like a reinforced tank I have known
exactly the kind of thought you are
since the moment you entered if ark had
no involvement in the bombing
it might justify going in right it goes
packing their security systems using the
architecture to my advantage
delivering concussive velocity of a peps
gun and the line to the Tesla's
electrified projectiles to avoid any
unnecessary deaths a lack of casualties
would be a show of respect to someone
like Rooker and might just convince him
to peacefully turn himself in faced with
two terrible choices I choose the lesser
evil I will come
but she and arc represent just one facet
of my hunt for the treasure
and I'll need to keep tracking down
leads and making contacts on both sides
of the wall if I hope to uncover the
true motives behind these escalating
attacks it's not always about doing that
I think or about doing things but I'd
wave them to us now Intel gathered from
allies outside the task force has made
questioning everything including the
true intentions of my own command if
you're meeting with Miller be careful
you're walking through another ambush
and Miller's not off the suspect list
yet everyone's got their agenda many all
have to trust my gut when dealing with
suspects how far are you willing to go
to help out the friend beneath whether
I'm working by the book going rogue
choice never comes without consequence
what's the going rate for cops in the
city you're making a very dangerous
assumption the clock is always ticking
the mystery on my own terms may be the
only way to prevent disaster
there is a moment coming and it will be
soon when all of us will have to choose
aside
as an G all conflicts become a global
concern
represents just one square on a giant
chess board whose pieces are continually
manipulated from the shadows
I have to choose my allies wisely
finding myself of the greater cause
they obscure themselves in darkness
is still mine to reveal
I don't care that they only speak in
whispers
I won't let them have the last word